Hello. I'm Hank Green, the guy whose voice
you hear in a lot of Microcosmos videos.
This is my face and this is my office.
And I'm here to unbox the base
model of the Microcosmos Microscope.
When I first started
getting interested in microscopy,
it was very intimidating for me to try
and figure out what microscope to get.
And so I'm really happy that we at Journey To The Microcosmos are able to provide
the thing that we think is the best thing
to get you started.
And I'm going to put it on the desk here.
You'll see it. There it is.
This is what it will arrive looking like.
The first thing you will find
when you open it up is the manual.
We built this manual up from scratch
so you would understand
all the different parts
of your microscope, how to use it,
doing your first samples, getting ready.
There's also a QR code that links to
a bunch of video tutorials that we have.
And this also is available
as a PDF and all updated versions
will be available
at microcosmos.store and then
there's
probably a bunch of ways to do this. But
oh yeah, it's upside down now,
then turn it right back right side up.
Oh yeah, Look at that baby.
“Enjoy the journey and share
what you find.” We do very much
want to see your videos
that you take with this.
I don't care if it's just some diatom
slowly gliding across the frame.
I want to see what you find.
We also have a submission
form on the website
where you can actually submit your footage
to potentially be used
in a Microcosmos video.
We want to do like clips
of what y'all make.
Then this will slide off
if you give it enough reason to.
So we have the head.
Pull out the power cord here.
There's this which is our phone mount,
which is a new version of the phone mount.
A little bit of microscope oil
for the thousand times objective
and then our microscope itself.
This is just a blue light filter.
Shoved in there will also be your cover.
You want to cover your microscope
when you're not using it.
So dust
doesn't get on the lenses and stuff.
Hey! Hello!
The best part of buying
something is taking off
all the little things off of it.
So you've got little tissue paper
covering up the light source down there.
Little tissue paper
in this space for safety
and then a little tissue paper on the...
it’s the stage, is what that's called.
Twist this little guy.
Then you can pop this off.
And then slide this in here
and then twist it back in
so it doesn’t fall out.
Doo doot.
Take out these little guys, don’t
need those
because your eyepieces go in there.
Now remember
eyepieces are always loose, so
do not turn your microscope upside down.
The eyepiece will come out and fall
onto the ground and little switch.
Light is on.
I'm seeing a bunch of magnified
nothing now this is just magnified light.
So there's a bunch of ways
to control your microscope.
You've got the amount of light
that's coming out of the light source
and that's adjustable here.
These here are your focus knobs.
The big one is, you know, big focus.
The small one is more fine focus.
There's this little thing
that actually collects the light
and focuses it on to the slide
that's called the condenser.
And you can move it up and down.
And that affects how the light hits
the slide.
And there's also a diaphragm
on the condenser, a little wiggly
piece of metal that will bring the light
sort of more into a point
which can affect how it looks.
Basically, if you play around with it,
you'll start to see what I mean.
And then on this side,
this actually moves the stage around
so that you can look around the slide
or follow any critters
that are running around.
And that is the thing you'll get better
at fastest
is what I've found is like
when I first started,
I was like, everything's backwards
and it's so confusing.
And then after
using it for a little while,
I got very good
at it like not as good as James, but good.
This is our phone mount that will come
with a separate little instruction manual.
There's also instructions in the guide
for how to use the phone mount.
Now, as you put your eyes on a microscope,
you'll see that there's a pretty small
point of light as you approach it,
and it's easier with your own head
to get your eyes in the exact same space
because you've been moving your head
around for your whole life.
It's take some time after
you clamped this on here to get the it
right lens of your camera
focused on the right point of light.
So it's a little fiddly,
but you fiddle around for a while
and then you're able to do it.
And I actually find
that it can be more comfortable
to be using the phone mount
for long periods of time,
because I'm just looking at the screen
rather than sort of hunching
into the microscope.
So now we're going to use the microscope
as intended.
I’m going to set up
my camera to be in here,
and we have our prepared anatomy slides,
which are also available
at microcosmos.store
and the box is so cool.
So this goes on here, clamps on.
So we're lining up the mount with right
kind of flush with the eyepiece.
You can see that right here, basically
on the same plane as the eyepiece.
And then I'm going to get this boy
in here, which is going to take a while
because I've got a big phone.
Now with my phone,
I have to clamp low down
so that I can actually get the lens up
to where the hole is
and slide that on there.
Now, first I got to set to my
make sure I'm set to my double
lens, my two x,
I use ProCam to, to do this
because otherwise Apple will mess with you
because it's trying to fix everything.
All right, now I've got my
sort of little circle right in the middle
and I'm going to try and clamp it
there it is.
Beautiful.
And then I'm going to zoom in
and then I don't know what this is going
to be some loose connective tissue.
My favorite kind of connective tissue.
I'm seeing some pink.
Let's try and focus.
Focus, focus.
A Oh, gross.
This isn't this isn't the sexiest of
objects to observe.
Ciliated epithelium. Great.
I actually do want to see some ciliated
epithelium now that I'm thinking about it.
Some beautiful cells here to work with.
See all those nuclei in there?
So this is all stained, so it looks extra
good.
Now, we also have plan
objectives available.
So slightly higher quality lenses
which you can get a set of all four
to replace all the ones you have
if you have the base model
and want to upgrade.
We also have the 20 X
and the 60 X available separately
if you just want to get those one, one
or both of those on their own.
I've just put in a lymph node.
Oh yeah. Hello.
My gosh.
Boy, I tell you what,
I know nothing about histology.
This is not my area of expertise now,
also on the bottom of our microscope,
there is a filter tray.
You can put that blue eyed filter
that comes with the microscope
or we have a set of various filters
that do various things
and Rheinberg filters
that will change the color of an image.
So without the filter
and then we're going to slide the filter
in place and see what happens.
You see there
you get like a dark field effect,
which on anatomy slide
is not like the greatest thing
because it's been dyed
for like the specific purpose, but
with your microbes at your pond
locally looks fantastic.
Now, the thing to note is
when we're saying
like 40 X or 20 x or 60 x,
when it comes to the objectives,
that's going to be multiplied by ten
because each one of these eyepieces
also is a ten x,
So a 40 x is actually 400 times
magnification because it's got
the 40 times the ten of the eyepieces.
There's a fair bit to know
about microscopy, but I'll tell you what,
as soon as you start to do it, it becomes
you have all of this incentive to learn
and and then suddenly wake up one day
and you know,
the difference
between a dinoflagellate and a rotifer,
which if you watch this show,
you're probably already there.
See, it's time to take the next step
and start on your own journey
into the microcosmos
with this beautiful object
that I love having it in my office,
but this one's not for me, it's for you.
We're going to pack it back up.
I'm going to sign the instruction
manual for you.
This is the base model.
You can also get an upgraded version
that has the plan objectives,
which are higher quality optics
already installed on the microscope.
That is also available
at microcosmos.store.
As I always say
at the end of these episodes.
Thank you for coming on this journey
with us.
I really am grateful.
It's a very enriching part of my life
to be a part of this channel
and also to have a deeper relationship
with that part of our world
that is so invisible to us
but is always out there.
And I hope very much that we can continue
inviting people
into that world through our videos,
but also through this microscope.
And if you capture something
that you would like to share with us,
we again
have that form on microcosmos.store.
From all of us here
at Journey to the Microcosmos,
including Matt sitting right there
filming me in my office.
Thank you so much for your support
and your interest in this bizarre world
that we all get to inhabit.